Hai, nama saya Katie Boslado,
saya Pengarah Strategi dan
Penyelidikan Aplikasi IBM Quantum. Saya di sini untuk menyanggah
sebanyak mungkin mitos pengkomputeran kuantum
dalam masa enam puluh saat.
Komputer kuantum itu benar-benar wujud,
dan kami ada peranti di IBM Cloud yang boleh diakses oleh sesiapa sahaja.
Ya, tapi hanya untuk benda-benda tertentu yang memang ia bagus buat,
seperti matematik yang sangat kompleks, macam yang menjalankan alam semesta ni.
Tapi kalau nak buat spreadsheet atau hantar emel, guna je
PC kamu.
Ya, secara teorinya, tapi bukan
dalam masa terdekat. Tiada siapa yang buat komputer yang cukup bagus untuk buat tu
lagi. Buat masa yang boleh dijangka, kita masih on track,
dan bila kita sampai ke sana, kita akan ubah cara kita melindungi
maklumat.
Itu langsung tak betul. Komputer kuantum
berbeza secara asasnya
dan guna hukum alam untuk memproses maklumat.
AI hari ini berjalan di atas peranti klasik biasa,
tapi kami percaya ia akan bekerjasama pada masa depan.
Tak betul. Kami ada ekosistem yang luar biasa
yang terdiri daripada syarikat permulaan, akademia, makmal kebangsaan, dan rakan industri yang
menggunakan peranti kami setiap hari.
Tidak, pengkomputeran terinspirasi kuantum dah lama wujud
dan berjalan di atas peranti klasik. Ia
tak akan pernah capai janji pengkomputeran kuantum sebenar.
Kalau kamu nak pengkomputeran kuantum, kamu kena buat dengan komputer kuantum
yang sebenar.